Sam uh welcome back to the show today
was not a difficult game against Wesley
with the black pieces it felt that maybe
you will get a repetition early on but
he kept the game going and he kept
trying to push you over the edge tell us
a bit about the game tell us a bit about
how you reacted to yesterday's loss very
difficult loss as
well yeah I mean uh yesterday was a
really tough day um I was just much
worse out of the opening and kind of
defended really well until the time
control but after you know moves 40 and
41 I just spent way too much time and
didn't have time to either win or even
draw that position at the end yeah how
psychologically how do you recover do
you get a good night's sleep or what do
you do when those difficult moments I I
just I just try to forget the game I
mean uh I did win the first game which
kind of Les lessened the blow a bit so
I'm still on 50% and I just thought like
like that you know the tournament starts
now nine round event absolutely always
try to see the positive side of things
and uh today's game did you feel at any
point that you're losing control maybe
you felt at any point that you're even
better towards the
end uh yeah I mean it was definitely a
lot of pressure and he played this line
which is very tricky I didn't check it
today and uh I think I kind of defended
pretty well with this Knight D5 knight6
F4 yes he had this very interesting idea
with um Queen C7 Queen B7 I don't know
if it's been played
before yes Rook E8 B4 uh Rook fd1 yeah
Queen
G4 here I was calculating a really
interesting line white goes Knight
E5 Queen G1 check very important line uh
King E2 Queen takes
A1 yes uh Rook takes E7 Rook takes C7
Queen B8 check
Rook E8 Knight D7
check King E7 Queen B7
uhhuh and it's very important I mean I I
thought you have to find Queen D1 here
you do
yes that's a nice one takes you on rook
d8 and yeah and Black's just better the
two yeah so I spent a lot of time on
this kn95 because if 95 works I'm just
lost I think right um yeah trading
Queens is just a horrible end game but
he went for this Rook takes E7 which I I
initially thought was pretty simple for
black but turns out there were some
practical problems mhm with uh I mean
here he could put the King on C4 as well
instead of
C2 I thought maybe that's the best try
yes just I I didn't see a reason why why
not to play King C4 right yeah Queen to
A8 Queen to E8 take the pawn take the
other Pawn as well I think there's one
interesting difference so if you put the
king here I would play G6 and if you put
the King on
C2 uh like the game was
I I think here I played Queen C6 I
should yeah maybe G6 Queen takes C5 King
G7 just get out of the but with a king
on C4 you cannot go Queen to C6 because
Queen takes C5 and that's a losing end
game right right exactly maybe this is
the best way to defend yeah because
after Queen C6 he found this very strong
move Rook
E1 which stops the Perpetual check and
uh wow H5 is okay here interesting well
H5 the thing about moves like H5 is
after Queen B8 check Queen
E8 I have to now I guess calculate these
Rook endings which are prob far
dangerous for
right I basically never wanted to play a
rook ending but I'm thinking uh can I
play King D7 here yeah Rook takes C5
maybe Rook C8 Rook C8 no Rook C8 is
maybe still a draw but yeah good luck
calculating this yeah I I I I definitely
don't want to do that yeah yeah so
practical ofing CH of course yeah of
course so I went for this G5 uh Rook E5
Queen C5 Queen A4 King C3 and I think I
found King F6 really nice move yes uh
best move in because uh because if H6
his trick is to go Queen
D4 and then Rook C Rook C8 check Rook C5
check yep and uh and Things become
difficult if not completely losing it
could be it might be completely losing
yeah I mean my pawns are so slow for
gain two is really difficult uh so yeah
we got this position rookie eight yeah
King B3 yeah I think this is the
critical position for from his
perspective after Rook B5 mhm uh I think
he missed Queen C3 Queen A8 which is a
very nice move it stops Queen h8 and
also wants to play Queen D5 and there's
no Queen D3 because of Rook F5 I here I
thought it was completely fine yeah uh
instead of queen queen C3 I was thinking
maybe B4 I know it's risky but B4 was
the best if you want to try you you
probably yeah maybe you have to try this
yeah Queen B6 King B3 Rook
F5 maybe King B3 now yeah but this is
dangerous yeah for both sides what yeah
the good thing is black can also
definitely win this position it's so
risky for what three uh three result
game for sure he didn't go for that and
uh you guys ended up splitting the point
uh Sam congratulations think final
position was uh I think the final
position is just a draw yes you can try
a little bit with F5 but you know the
engine is saying you're really you're
doing really well here but as you move
along through the lines it becomes
apparent it's not that easy que okay
yeah so here A6 and I think Queen to A7
was a big one and F3 Queen to A7 I think
is probably the most difficult uh move
to deal with I'm going to I think Queen
a A6 check was an idea for white instead
of Queen D6
check Queen to A6 okay King H5 King H5
yes Queen B7 Queen to B7 and now
F3 A6 and queen E2 and I guess you want
to fight with two
queens Ah that's that's amazing
okay and just play this position with a
pawn up and maybe this is yes I
understand this looks good for you for
sure looks
equal you can take a PA but I'm hiding
you know Four Queens looks like
calculating this after like four hours
of playing feels equal yeah yeah it was
a yeah F5 was a was a was an opportunity
yeah okay it's it was a very interesting
game it was our congratulations Sam it
was a tough save uh Wesley with the
white pieces who was really putting on
the pressure and uh we thought you
handled it really well seriously
congratulations all right thank you
absolutely and what's happening